e aos 15 anos de idade foi lançado o
maior desafio da minha vida eu sair de
uma aula de balé e fui fazer juntamente
com os meus pais um trabalho voluntário
no instituto de cegos Padre Chico a
diretora do Instituto viu a minha
postura e falou nossa as crianças do
Instituto tem uma postura tão arqueada
Você não quer vir ensinar baller para
que elas melhorem a postura e autoestima
eu com 15 anos de idade pensei eu
ensinar balé mas eu nunca dei aula nem
para crianças em nenhuma deficiência me
considerava totalmente insegura e
incapaz para começar um trabalho com
crianças tão especiais
e foi aí que meus pais falaram as
palavras mais sábias que eu ouvi na
minha vida eles disseram filha nunca
fala não para um desafio pois são sempre
destes Desafios que partem os maiores
ensinamentos que nós temos nas nossas
vidas eu acredito que essas palavras
Entraram na minha vida e no meu coração
de modo que eu tô ao longo destes mais
de 22 anos realizando esse trabalho
voluntário e com certeza foi o trabalho
que mais me enriqueceu como ser humano
através dessas meninas desses meninos eu
aprendo a cada dia a fechar os olhos da
visão que são extremamente
preconceituosos e abrir os olhos do
coração e ver um mundo mais bonito o
mundo com muito mais significado
é só que nem sempre foi fácil quando eu
cheguei para dar minha primeira aula de
balé Eu imaginei que elas vão estar
prontas de coque e sapatilha meia calça
como qualquer criança quando vai para
sua primeira aula de balé e quando eu
cheguei elas estavam de cabelos soltos
diz calças calça jeans eu falei mas
vocês que vão fazer balé elas falaram
balé o que que é balé Cadê você quem é
você quando elas começaram me tocar e
sentir como uma bailarina se colocava
antes de dançar elas falaram Nossa que
bonito que mágico você vai ensinar isso
pra gente com certeza e quando eu fui
ensinar o primeiro passo de balé que se
chama esse a pessoa tem a bailarina ela
tem que saltar abrindo as pernas e sal
tá fechando as pernas para ficar mais
fácil e o processo de ensino
e eu falei imagina que vocês estão
saltando fora de um balde e dentro de um
balde e para minha surpresa aluna
levantou a mão e falou tia mas o que que
é um balde eu nunca vi foi nesse momento
que eu percebi o quanto eu precisava
entrar no mundo do deficiente visual
fechar os meus olhos entender como eles
entendiam o mundo para que depois eu
pudesse apresentar o meu mundo da dança
clássica quero que eu tava disposta
então foi essa troca de mundos que fez
nascer um método todo através da do
toque e da percepção corporal as alunas
vão tocando nosso corpo sentindo o
movimento e depois reproduzido no seu
próprio corpo e esta magia acabou
contagiando essas meninas de que tudo é
possível quando se tem força de vontade
e se acredita num sonho hoje com muito o
eu falo que a única companhia
profissional de ballet de cegos no mundo
recebendo aplausos pelo mundo afora não
pela deficiência e sim pela Bela Arte
pela qualidade que elas vêm mostrando no
palco porque era assim que eu gostaria
que elas fossem vistas pelo público as
guerreiras nos palcos e na vida desde o
primeiro dia de aula elas aprendem que
uma bailarina deve sempre olhar para as
estrelas mesmo que não as enxergue E é
isso que elas vem fazendo brilhando há
muitos anos como as estrelas e um dia eu
cheguei desanimada pensando em desistir
é porque eu não consegui ensinar a
leveza de uma bailarina tem que ter ao
dançar elas dançavam todas muito do
linhas muito firmes e eu não consegui
entender aquela leveza aí eu ficava
pensando a ele sempre vão falar vale de
cegos é bonito mas elas nunca dançam
completas como uma bailarina tem que ser
com movimentos firmes de perna e suaves
de braços e aí quando eu pensei em
desistir eu tive um grande sonho eu
sonhei que eu não tinha braços eu sonhei
que meus braços eram duas folhas de
Palmeiras e se você observar o vento
quando bate na folha da Palmeira é
exatamente o mesmo movimento que uma
bailarina tem que ter ao dançar quando a
gente conectou essas Palmeiras nos
braços dessas bailarinas ela se tornaram
bailarinas muito mais completas Então
hoje elas estão dançando fora do país
que eu como bailarina nunca dancei elas
estão dançando ballet de repertório mais
de
os cartórios coisas que eu como
bailarina não consegui então eu não
queria que elas parassem no meu nível
como bailarina Foi aí que foram
contratados professores muito muito
melhores do que a Fernanda o que eu
quero e mostrar para o mundo que o
impossível não existe essas meninas
mostram que todas as barreiras devem ser
enfrentadas e derrubadas
ó E além disso que a luz que vem de
dentro delas que a beleza que vem de
dentro delas possa ser espalhada por
todos e compartilhada porque quando eu
me envolvi no mundo e ela se envolveram
no meu a gente criou esta metodologia
Depois de alguns anos apenas com
deficientes visuais foram lançadas
propostas para outros tipos de
deficiência Então hoje Associação
Fernanda Bianchini atende gratuitamente
380 alunos com idades entre 3 anos até
terceira idade aprendendo balé clássico
sapateado teatro música dança de salão
dança do ventre e todas as atividades
e a gente percebe o quanto a arte
transforma lágrimas em sorrisos e é esse
o nosso maior objetivo eu me sinto
agradecida por Deus por ter sido
escolhida e capacitada para um projeto
tão lindo e tão transformador de vidas e
é isso que nós queremos levar e que
essas pessoas possam sonhar conosco e
transformar muito mais vidas e muito
mais sonhos em realidade essa história
não é da Fernanda essa história é um
conjunto de muitas outras vidas e foram
essas vidas transformadas que nós vamos
finalizar com vocês através da
coreografia olhando para as estrelas com
a única companhia profissional de ballet
de cegos no mundo tema do nosso
documentário Oi
as estrelas porque era isso que as
alunas ouviam desde a primeira aula uma
bailarina deve sempre olhar para as
estrelas mesmo que não assim cheque
muito obrigada
E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
E aí
[Aplausos]